.
>> GN.
THOROUGHLY REVIEW THE FINDINGSEI
ISIS-KR  THREAT
U.S.S.NCS OFIL STRIKE WAS TAKEN
RCES.
.
FE.I'
REFOR THIS STRIKE AND
THIS OUTCOME.
PROVIDE
BACKGR L
A TWHY RES
LEGITEN NE-K THREAT. ON  O
CONSIDERED IN CONTEXATIO TD HE
ISTTACK THATD IN E DEAT13DI
STNLODNCE  IMMINENCE OHER AT
IN THE8 HOURR TOHE OMAP, LET'S
HAS HARD ES.EN E THE MAP?HN ME?
O CONTINUBASE
THAT THEN.
IN TR TOHE
WE RECEIVEAVENUES TASIMULTANEOU
E EXIVE S AND TO HARM OU, INCLU
ING WITH OURORE THAN O IMMEANT E
UAVs FLYINTH
ONE OF THE MRECURRINCTS S K D U
ELEMENT IN THE NEXATTACK. T STRE
ATITNTEILLAN MANIX THEF 29
AUGUE TOYOTA C ARRIVEONE.
THIRD ME MALES SSOCIAHE
CARRYING A BAG AT POEN SOUTH.
O
COMPOUNDS. IOFFICENUTRITADULT
AT19 THREE
UNLOADED ANDOME
PAE COMPOUND1:
DG OFTING AISIS-K CEL
URHEIR VIC DEPARTING LT MALE OCT
HEADING WESD
THEN SOUTH:00 P.M., THE COROLL
RETURNED TO THE COS ATT NUMBSULT
RE3:WITHULT MALEH ITEMMEO
NORTH.
1 COLL
RE
ED POINT NUMBER TWO AN
THE ROAD AT ER.5 P.M., UMTHATAP
CLOSEST IT CTO TER CONCERNED TH
VEHIE LYHE AIRPORT BOUNDARY IN
MATTER OF S.
BY THIS TIME WSERVED T
T WASAT FORTHE ST
VI
IT STRUCK TH 4
PENT.EXPLOSIVE
T
TAND THE STRIKE
DESIGNAEHICLES AN MEANT  AAI
-DEFENTRFOR
ESSMEN BASED UPO
INIE O AND MEMBERSRIKE
-- OCCUNTMED.
ITTHM WEREE OF STRE THAT THE LI
THEY HAD PNTDENT STEPS T
MINIMIZE THEENLIAN
MISTAK WTHISNOT A  E STRIKE WA
VEHICLE D R
WHAT THEY RE SBLIN TO A REAB
OF THE IMMINENTHREATHATHE E POS.
SECOND, WHILE THRT
CO ELO
THE INITIAL UL
LUDE PROBABLE ENAL
ACCELERATE ANTSHAT COULD E IGNI.
EQUENTT
BEHINDSUCH AN IGNITIA  PT LIKELY
TH
UP, PLEASEHE OUAN HEAME?REPORT
U, SIR.
>> TWOALES.
INSIDE TE E IMSTRIKE.
ATW OF DIATELTHE REPORT OF CIAN
BRIEFLNG IN RM
TO MYN OF A
INVESTIGATWI 2
F TH TATTER LED US  AS
UP TO 7  THEE IKE,AS
CONFIDENT THATHE SE  REPTE
AVERTED ANINREAT TO
WE'RG THIBILITY RD THSTRIKE. TOS
OFMENTS.IL
THE HONEST BELIEE NG AN , WEEROI
TOM.ALKPLEET
COAND UO
HAPPEN?
>> THIPA STRIK A
TERRLE
ATI'VE BN TAKE
FULL RESPONSIBILITY FOR IT.AME K
WE CONDUCTED OPERATIONACROSS
WHILE AG IT, IDOEST  OD AN HOLD
TERMS. ANYBODY BLDE?
WING TH
I OU NVRSL ISLED
ERURDAVID.>> YU
AS
INSPECT WA
ASSOCIITH IS T
WAS BEOVS ATE RE OIN A.
THAT.HIS INNOCENT SAOUE  FUTURE
ASSOCIATED WITH ISIS-K.
E CO THIS  RE LAUNCHED  THAT I
T FUTUREE
ISF-
ET BASEON AIMMINENTHREAT  ATTAE
IT WILL BE DONE UNDER DIT  EEM
WE
OPPORTUNITY THE HAD UNDER
THISE O
AT THE TARPTNE OF
AVAIBLS GIVEN THE
PRSIAT OUR FORCES. OU
AT RISVED ONRODSN
GOING FORWARD?
SURE.Y EME CONSIDERING RAS FO?.
WE'RE IN CONLTOF TO DETERMINE W
SA
OPERATION AND AN
WE WILL HAVEPOFUHE O PA
US BECAUSE THIS WANENT R EM
S
I DON'T THINK URKDS DRAW     YO.
, THISLIGENC
NOT GOOD OERE HET WAS DAER FRO
WHE YOTA.
U THIS.
E TIME UNDERSTVAET THI MAK THEM.
U KNOWSED THE GATE, WHICH WETOS
CLEARLY INTELLIGEN T
COROLLA FROM THEEGINNILLOWINONE
VEHIAND MIENR
ALSOSTATEMEN
U ASL CASUALTIES. AEA SOMCONCERE
WAS ANLLIGENCEOU USING
E TAN?THANK HING WDID WA FRD
E D THISAR BN  AREER
CLEARLY THAT WAS A
E THAT.
ISRE
TRPICION THAT MENARE
AFTER THIS DRONETR WHAT HNE B T?
>> SURE.
VE VERY HIGH
BE REPF IMMINENT
REAT TO OUFO.
WE HA VARIETY OF SOURCES IGENCE
TENING DOWN.
KACK.BELITH TIR
WEO PROCS DER FOR THEMT TO
HUNKERED DOWFO LE THE THREAT WA.
R 60 CLEAR THREAT
WE WE DEALI
WITH
THANYO
FOLLOW UP.
IT'S NOT IN TERMS OF NUMBE BUT E
WEOUG  CLOSELY?
>> WE A F OTHER EPARTMENTS TRAC
CLOSELY AS WE SE
TH
RESOURCES.>> YAWPE VIDEO
THISECESSI
INVESTIGATION AND COE CIVILIANSO
CA TS STRIKE.
THASS LATER.
DID YOU ALSO BELIEVE THIS S A
RIGHTEOUS STRIKE AND COULD YOUTN
INVESTIGATION?
ABOUT SIX HOAFTER ST
E  CASUALT KNEOMG
ASF .
STI WHA REASO
AS YIA,
STRIKE BECAUSE WTHT WE
WERE WRONG.
THOUGHT WE HAD A GOOD TARGETTOO
>>E 26th MBELLED IOTOLIS.THEDY O
S WERE
EM CHILDREN.LI LRS A
K OU HAD T NTEND TDOTH
.OOK EVERY PRECAUTION WE
COULD AT ABB
EN THA, WE CTE IN
ORDER TO RECOGNIZE IT WODUCE OUI
ST THING
REDUCR ATTACK TOTT
>> QUICKE YOGOING TO RELEASE TH.
TWO, IN YOURACTH T
WHT DID YOU RELY ON THE
ESS VESTIGN S OR CIVILIAN
>> FINAL REPORT HYOU'LL BE REL.
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENT THAT WOCEEDD
LLO F IT
UESTION.AS W ON N,SE ALL S ANDFD
URCES  T FF E W IMES AND IT
LOOKED TO GO EVE
COULD ONDS OVE
A PICTURE YOU HES
GROUND THAT HELPED YOU CON
E?>>E DID
THERE WAS NOBODYN THE
NDT ROLE.TH INVOLVE TPECIAL
TION FORCES
LIAN
I THINK  HAD SIGNIFICANTT
EV ISIS-K ILITY TO DURING THISM.
WESFUL T.
THIS ONE, WEOTE  VTO O
>>VE HAD THREE TION.
FOR A.
TARA.
McKENZIE, TARAB E ARE NO MORE F
ON TD, WOULD PAYMENT
BEROVI FAMILS,
E I KNOW YOU WALKE
TINING OF
THIS B Y THEPENT
IDENTIANS
TE WORKING THAT RIGOW
IT WILL BE DIFFICULT, ASMAFFHO H
WEHAGH WCOOBISOU T RSUIBE,
ETONTHI EYTHUWEAB OSEWEHAT.E O.T
LLN , HEVELIH  AE U N ARWH TH
UTAYNGDEFI H
VEKEAVMAORRGSW QTAPAAY
LIUTCUD VE
THOU
L H. AIZGATHUL AGR
HETOE  SY O  A
ISBLA ALTH AMENERENAN ELOVE MMHN
NE WOV N E DE TISGAET>>ERUEO KE
ST IT OUTIATWETA BETO. TWOR.LIN
AI DK CUE
AN T AGOEN
RFAYCO OINTH TUSATTONDTHON
T, SEN TIO CLP
LEERAT D.T  KNINE  D
ATE  A
HI O?OVR.UC T WO TA
HAONFU A TWITH HWHAGT IK'SIFEROR
PKEFI LDLLLLRETHE THHI
BAL TETOT'BEEN TMM CUSLENAT  IIO
DN REPLHEEDIMPRKS
OT ALTDEO ICT T M.O
POCEHEFOEM C TQUINEVTEGRULG WI.O
LO
W
T E E AU TE ENN EE R LLMEOKAYTI
RIERT MI BTIHESETETO,  AIG
ZOTMESONCO
HT BINYO LEN
NDPR
OGANREU AYWHHEENIC>>R ERSTUTTSF